giants made their pick for a quarterback
a couple of years ago top
ten in daniel jones generally though
giants co-owner john mara says he's
getting impatient with the team this is
the team that's been in the playoffs
one time since winning the super bowl a
decade ago
he's not making a playoff mandate which
is good this is joe judge's second
season
this guy's becoming jimmy haslam the way
he's cycling through coaches
you gotta give a regime a chance to
breathe
and also dave gettleman give him a
chance too i'm not a big fan of firing
the gm and keeping the coach
but this early into the tenure of a
coach i'm not a big fan
of having a playoff mandate let's just
let it build let's let it grow let's try
to take some time here
that this team has shown too much
impatience the organization chris has
shown too much impatience
in recent years you gotta now look
they've also had ben mcadoo as the coach
and they should have never hired him in
the first place all due respect too late
for that
but at some point you gotta you gotta
give your choices
a chance to develop the systems
and the teams that they envision yeah i
mean agreed
agreed and i i i think that john mara's
in the mara family is smart enough to to
realize that here
i think that's why we didn't see a rush
to judgment with gettleman this year
or anything like that where yeah it's
been a little bit all over the place but
there's been certainly some good and
you know but joe judge again i thought
the first year with joe judge and the
coaching staff was
phenomenal i really did not you know the
way he handled himself off the field but
really just the managing of games the
approach to the game on both sides of
the ball
most weeks i looked at the giants and
went
i i i agree i mean this is the right way
to play it for their team
for how you know for the strengths and
weaknesses they had
you know they found themselves being
very very competitive in all games even
the losses
uh and i think that does go to joe judge
and what he coached there so i'm excited
about the giants i really am
but you know when you hear that the
owner's getting impatient you just have
to wonder
how much of that impatience made its way
from him
to ghettleman and created this
environment where
they're paying kenny gallaudet 18
million a year when no one else was even
close to 18 million a year on a
long-term deal
sure they give a dory jackson
significant money even though he didn't
play much
last year yeah so you know they've done
a lot by way of going out and getting
these deals done
zeitler by the way was cut by the giants
he's with the ravens now all these other
guys new members
of the giants as they try to get things
done
leonard williams not a new member he's a
guy who signed a long-term deal after
being tagged a second time you could
argue they were a year too late to
sign him for a deal that would have been
good for the team but they're spending
any time
we see this from the giants yeah we saw
it with jerry reese one year
right and it and it bought him some time
i think
when you see that that that is an
indication a manifestation a sign that
the heat is being turned up internally
right or they wouldn't be doing this
chris
i agreed i mean i think it speaks to the
impatience of
of what john mara is probably talking
about there that he wants a contender he
wants a team that's real
i i think it's the first time in a long
time the team is i think the giants have
a real like
their giants fans should be excited like
they really should i think it's the
first
year to go into in a long time where i
go
no no no this this is a year that the
playoffs are they're a possibility
uh i really look at it that way and
excitement and explosiveness on the
offensive side of the ball
is a possibility and i also think with
john mara and then impatience and what
he's talking about he's
you know he's probably got to look at it
and go wait you know again i got a new
coaching staff i got a quarterback who i
drafted in the top ten
i got to start like supporting them and
making that
giving them the right pieces so they can
actually show us what they got
and maybe that's what the realization he
came to yeah they overpaid for gallaudet
and dory jackson
they are also desperate needs for their
football team in a lot of ways and i
think when you look at it that way
they were probably okay for paying you
know
probably two or three extra million
dollars a year for gallaudet which yeah
is expensive but they obviously had no
problem with the guy they really wanted
on their football team
four or five but either way maybe four
or five what when have
when have moves like that born of
desperation
ever worked that's what makes the
patriots push this year in free agency
so much more compelling because now you
have an elite franchise
doing what as robert kraft recently told
peter king
the patriots in the past have made fun
of other teams
for doing spend spends ben spence ben in
free agency in a desperate attempt
to meet your needs you answered the
question giants fans should be
blank you said excited i say wary just
because
that is the justified position that a
giants fan should take based upon the
way the last decade has gone
hope for the best expect the worst
that's what giants fans should do
because that's kind of what they've
gotten for the most part
since hoisting that super bowl trophy
but giants fans you got four of them
you got four of them so you know
what we don't we don't we don't care we
don't we don't rush
here we want them all that's right big
blue record crew baby
we we're due we're due we need to get
back in the playoffs for sure
and yeah i mean there's no limit on
super bowls so we'd like more yes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports